Harry Hippo awoke early one morning.
"OW!" he moaned.
"I have a horrible, terrible toothache."
Harry moaned and groaned.
He moaned and groaned so loudly he woke everyone up.
"What is wrong?" they asked.
"Why is Harry moaning and groaning so loudly?"
"Harry has a toothache," said his wife, Harriet.
"What shall we do?" asked Polly the Parrot.
"We will have to pull out the tooth," said Harriet.
"But who will pull it out?" asked Polly.
"I will," said Milly the Gorilla.
"But how will you pull it out?" asked Ziggy the Lion.
Milly went off to find a vine.
She tied the vine to Harry's tooth, and she pulled on the vine.
She pulled and pulled, but the tooth did not come out.
"Let me help," said Ziggy.
So Ziggy and Milly pulled, but the tooth did not come out.
"What will we do now?" asked Polly.
"I have an idea," said Milly.
They took Harry to a cliff and tied the vine to a big rock.
They pushed the rock over the cliff.
But Harry's tooth did not come out.
"Now what?" asked Ziggy.
"I have a better idea," said Polly, and she flew off.
Harry moaned and groaned even louder.
Later, Polly came back with Ella the Elephant.
"Ella will help us pull Harry's tooth," said Polly.
They tied the vine to Ella.
She pulled and pulled, but still the tooth did not come out.
Then out of the jungle crept a mouse.
Ella saw the mouse and took off running very fast.
Out came Harry's tooth.
Harry stopped moaning and groaning.
Once again the jungle was quiet.
Everyone was happy, especially Harry.